let's go next to our caller from the two
four zero area code caller from two four
zero who's this
where are you calling from uh honey
David can you hear me yes I can hi my
name is Marilyn all right so I'm an
economics major and I support
progressively higher income taxes on the
extremely wealthy and I've been talking
to my father who was more what you call
a corporate Democrat okay and he does
support these extremely high taxes on
the wealthy he points to papers and
studies let's say if you increase taxes
on them they'll find even more ways to
pay some less taxes so I just want to
know what your opinion is on that well
that's if they are allowed to do that I
mean people people will okay so listen
in general people are going to there's a
difference between tax avoidance and tax
evasion tax avoidance means using legal
means to reduce your tax liability tax
evasion is when we typically talk about
criminal activity criminal tax evasion
if you raise a tax rate on paper and
then add some kind of loophole or say
that only applies to wages but you can
reclassify your income in this other way
and not pay taxes on it of course
anybody with the resources to avail
themselves of accounting advice is going
to do that and that that actually that's
not a secret right and I even pointed
out when when people say a 90 percent
top marginal rate is something we did in
the past when we had it in the past it
was at a time when there were so many
deductions and exempt income that that
high rate applied to a tiny tiny
fraction of anyone's income so it wasn't
really effective
it wasn't an effective rate in any kind
of serious way so sure I mean your dad's
right people will try not to pay taxes
if they can avoid it legally but that's
why we have to look at the capital gains
tax that's why we have to look at
offshoring of money and repatriation and
all of this other stuff I mean your
dad's not wrong but that's not a reason
to say that the science around a 70
percent top marginal rate as being the
rate that maximizes government revenue
that science is still sound yeah I agree
I think the IRS has so many resources to
go after people that if they really
wanted to they could definitely go after
the very wealthy that wants but their
money overseas it's not about the the
IRS having the resources to go after
people go after implies they've they've
already broken some kind of law the
point is we have to determine what the
law is if you say seventy percent
marginal tax rate but it's fifteen
percent on capital gains CEOs can say
hey I'll just take a dollar salary and
pay me just in distribution you know I'm
saying yeah Todd could you can ask one
more question sure so I don't really
question this one no it's what your
opinion is on the Venezuela the us's
hypocrisy on Venezuela Saudi Arabia
there and some Marco Rubio is right now
in Venezuela the end that he wants to
bring democracy to them and all this
which I support I think they need to see
the situation there is absolutely
disgusting and there needs to be some
regime change there but the u.s. is
completely silent on all the
authoritarian oh crap I'm again I'm
against our relationship with Saudi
Arabia but I so you say you want to
bring regime change to Venezuela I'm
against that can you give me an example
of the u.s. bringing regime change in
Latin America that is gone now hold on
it's a well hold on a second and it I
don't know if we're now on speaker but
your connection is quickly deteriorating
my question was going to be is there an
example you can point to of the US
bringing democracy and regime change to
Latin America that has worked out well
I strongly I don't support the u.s.
bring regime change I think the people
there need to I really don't know if
there's a solution other than the Civil
War or Maduro finally realize
but he's a horrible human being which I
don't think will happen okay no then
we're on the same page yeah I mean the
Maduro needs to go and there needs to be
a regime change but it can't be crafted
think-tank regime change coming coming
from the United States I really
appreciate the call great to hear from
you wish your connection had been a bit
better